when you think about superpower status
uh he who rules the seas you've heard
that you've heard that phrase before
most people think that it is impossible
in the near term for the united states
to lose its global reserve currency
status
yeah and a lot of people
uh think that bitcoin can naturally rise
up and somehow displace the reserve
currency
you only have to dismiss 500 years of
history in order for that to happen
because at last check countries prefer
to have
that status as a way of dominating
the global economy so
what do you how do you envision the
evolution
or the loss of the dollar as a reserve
currency
status this is going to end up being the
last
the last part of our discussion sure
well we could talk about this forever
look i think the u.s dollar
reserve currency status exists
until it doesn't is it sounds like a
trite way to describe it but
it works right now because there really
aren't any alternatives there's no
viable alternative you thought maybe the
euro could rise to the ranks of that but
they fell apart they can't get their act
together the united states of europe is
not congealing
in fact it's disintegrating and so i
don't think that's got a really bright
future as a contender for a global
reserve currency
um you know do you go over to the yen
not really
a declining demographic profile you know
waning
uh economic influence doesn't really
have a military okay
um the chinese yuan well i don't really
quite
get the belief that people have the
authoritarian regimes that have
potentially nationalistic instincts
that i'm going to put my assets there
with the belief that rule of law that
they claim exists may not exist could
exist don't know if it exists
but i really needed to exist to put my
money there
so there's no alternative there really
isn't but
with that said the incentive structures
are stronger than they've ever been
for other countries that are jealous of
the quote-unquote exorbitant privilege
that we have
to be able to print to be able to have
effectively unlimited demand for what we
offer the world
uh and they're kind of jealous and
kind of angry about that and i think
they're going to work on trying to find
an alternative to the dollar
and by the way we've recognized it we've
fully weaponized the dollar
well bingo i was going to say the
weaponization of the dollar has also
contributed to that incentive structure
right uh you know using swift and all
these systems to sort of
uh you know attack and contain and
control
uh some of the
rogue or political
competitors i guess is the right word um
has the potential to really backfire in
the form of incentivizing
uh the emergence of an alternative now i
think it'll be really hard for an
alternative to emerge
i really do i don't think this is a
trivial undertaking
if it does lines up with an earlier
statement i think it'll probably need to
be some form of
hard currency backed by something
because people will have doubt
um and you know for years they'll test
whether or not that real
backing is in fact real so okay you're
gonna
give me x ounces of gold if i bring you
a a
whatever um call the currency wherever
you want
uh and people will test it like okay
here where's the gold give me this or a
precious metal or platinum or whatever
it is just give it to me i want to see
it
and they're going to test it for years
before they give it any real faith
um and they'll test it with small
dollars and it'll take time so we'll see
the alternatives emerge before they
actually emerge uh but don't
fool ourselves we shouldn't fool
ourselves i mean the the endeavor to
produce an alternative
is as strong as ever and like covet you
could see
inflation as being the accelerant so to
speak could be that's right
you